sie wollen auf und davon
birgit und jungs haben kinder
großgezogen jetzt ziehen sie los auf die
philippinen
die familie fischer aus dem aargau
wünscht sich mehr lebensqualität
sie bricht auf in die weite kann er das
vom appenzell ans mittelmeer
monika und berta sony aller folgen ihren
traum sie bauen ein kleines hotel in der
türkei
[Musik]
reiske
auf der reise nach williams lake ihrem
neuen zuhause übernachtet die familie
fischer auf einem campingplatz
es ist der erste abend im camper für die
frisch ausgewanderte familie in der
letzten folge von auf und davon
erhielten die fischers endlich das visum
kaum in kanada angekommen kauften sie
einen kenner
noch hat die familie kein haus in der
neuen heimat
[Musik]
hühnerfüße für die sens nach einem
exotischen willkommens essen so birgit
zum ersten mal ihr philippinisches
paradies sand mitbewohnerin auf ihrer
baustelle in der türkei kämpfte monika
und bertha mit ersten problemen
es ist nicht zu oben und burtons versuch
nicht zu rauchen wurde auf eine harte
probe gestellt
[Musik]
noch vor dem ersten nach dessen im neuen
heim auf vier rädern sorgt der
sechsjährige politischer für aufregung
[Musik]
nun kann pauli das erste curry
geschnetzelte ohne wackelzahn genießen
die fischers haben bei ihrer
auswanderung viel zurücklassen müssen
doch ihr familienleben das haben sie
mitgenommen
[Musik]
begehrt der türkische natursteine
schmücken die fassade des hotels von
monika und wärtern noch steht es erst im
rohbau
heute soll die terrasse betoniert werden
wie fast jeden tag nimmt bauherrin
monika einen augenschein
zusammen mit jemand wörtern wenn die
betonpumpe da wäre dann ging es
schneller weil es zu wenig ist haben in
dem punkt nicht geschickt weil punkte
brauchen öl war in großen lettern
ehrungen
deswegen wollten dann kommt er nicht
schicken zwei kubikmeter zement hat bert
angestellt gemäss seinem architekten
sollte das eigentlich mehr als genügend
wie schwer ist so eine schubkarre wenn
sie voll ist
das ist ja nicht mal die hälfte
bert anruft seinen architekten an
seine berechnungen stimmen nicht du hast
gesagt einen halb kubik seien genug die
haben aber nicht einmal für die hälfte
der terrasse gereicht
nach mega viel stress sind auf ihnen
lastet die ganze verantwortung alles
organisiert die ganze verhandlung nach
wie vor an fertig ich bin ich stolz für
wenigste wichtigste zum thema
materialien oder indem es mit dem umbau
zu erhalten machen wir da immer zweiter
aber alle sagen wo ich ja noch
hundertprozentig die besten wird auch
weil das berge organisieren machen
einmal mehr musste berthon zum rechten
schauen
das strapaziert die nerven auch wenn am
ende alles richtig kommt
[Musik]
an der espressomaschine mit 10 4 - oder
sind richtig froh das ist schöner luxus
seit einem monat nun neben birgit und
jörg seien auf der philippinischen insel
palawan fast jeden tag pendelten sie von
ihrem mietshaus in der stadt zu ihrer
baustelle direkt am meer
ab heute ist schluss mit pendeln ihr
bungalow ist bezugsbereit
mit den hunden dem labrador welpen chi
chi und mischling ziehen sie um in die
ferien resort
[Musik]
das neue zuhause der zürcher ist ein
stück land was zur groß wie ein
fußballfeld sexbombe was wollen sie hier
bauen ein restaurant und eine bar
[Musik]
das erste bungalow das beinahe
fertiggestellt ist wird ihr neues
zuhause
doch noch funktionieren die sanitären
anlagen nicht im ersten stock wird das
paar künftig schlafen
[Musik]
endlich die familie fischer kommt in
ihrem neuen wohnort williams lake
[Musik]
williams lebt von der holzwirtschaft
deshalb lässt sich zimmermann kurz mit
seiner familie hier nieder um williams
lake richtig anzuschauen bleibt jedoch
keine zeit kurth will sofort einen
besuch bei pioneer lockermachen jenem
blockhausbau unternehmen bei denen shop
als zimmermann gefunden hat
im lokal ich suche wert er ist gleich
dort vielleicht dort hinten
[Applaus]
am ende hat einfach die dadurch richtig
frei vor dem tor
die garden hotel meiner arbeit ja seit
wochen wartet kurz neuer arbeitgeber auf
den schweizer fachmann probleme mit der
kanadischen visums behörde hatten die
abreise der fischers verzögern
auch kurz künftiger chef bert ist 1
ausgewandert mitbringen
alles machen aber nicht so bezeichnen
nach dem rechner und finden der bhp zeit
dachstuhl zeichnen und ausreichend
längen berechnen und so weiter
dort auch einige oder gar nicht bis
anhin gemacht und das einzige was mit
mit holz oder aber mit rundholz muss
fahren und das ist also und der schwede
mit sagt ein banker mit direktbanken
oder julie meynen provisionen und danke
danke danke oder in der schweiz arbeitet
als selbstständiger zimmermann hier in
kanada ist der teil eines 20 köpfigen
teams kurz neuer arbeitgeber bot
blockhäuser jedes dieser zum teil
riesigen häuser wird zuerst komplett
aufgebaut dann wird jeder balken
nummeriert und das haus wieder zerlegt
um es am bestimmungsort dann definitiv
zu montieren
[Applaus]
dieses haus wird das erste sein welches
kurz aufrichten muss weit weg von hier
an einem see
[Musik]
in der türkei steht monika und wörtern
am beginn einer längeren einkaufstour
zunächst besuchen sie einen schreiner
dem jetzt oder rohbau steht brauchen sie
fenster an keine günstigen
kunststoffrahmen aus gutem holz müssen
sie sein
das hier sind zb fertig lackierte
fenster die auf den kundendaten die
zierleiste machen wir von hand
holzrahmen sind mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie einfache kunststoffrahmen beim
tee wird über den kauf details und vor
allem über den preis verhandelt für die
entscheidung relativ lange weitermachen
oder holt mit ihm holt sich ist also
regelmäßig mollet werde nach wie vor
teil der einzige vorteil ist einfach das
ist jetzt wirklich mit ja haben danach
ich im französischen abgang
bei diesem kauf geht es einerseits um
viel geld
mehr noch aber geht es um vertrauen um
vertrauen welches das paar in einander
haben muss denn für die preisverhandlung
ist immer wörtern zuständig aber wieso
männer die man stärke zeigen und wenn
eine frau wie ich denke jetzt keine noch
darum entscheide jedoch besser wenn sich
frau immer zurückziehen tage relativ
schnell gelernt
deine freiheit zur sache wir sprechen
natürlich auch immer zeigen wie es
wirklich um viel geld und er versuchte
browser namens drucker und dennoch
monika stellt sich auf eine lange
wartezeit ein
doch nach nur zehn minuten ist der
handel perfekt um 15 konnte bert an den
verkaufspreis runterhandeln
die geht das ja super klappt super
qualität und was meinst du vorher aus
einem geschäft gesehen das ist doch
jetzt von hier drehen die fahrt geht
weiter nach istanbul
das einkaufsparadies ist die nächste
etappe auf dem weg zum traumhotel dort
finden sie die größte auswahl auch für
die kleinen details ihres hotels
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am strand von cala wann feiern jörg und
berge ihren einzug ins resort das fest
ist vor allem auch ein dankeschön an die
bauarbeiter selbst ein feuerkünstler ist
für die party angereist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war
[Musik]
der nächste morgen ist trüb schlimmer
noch während der nacht hat es geregnet
[Musik]
das ist deshalb stehen weil das dach
offen war nicht dicht ist
[Musik]
nicht eben ein entspannter tagesbeginn
um die nachwehen des großen festes
auszukurieren hat beiden lassen auf der
weltgrößten klatschen aus jeder aber das
sind ja auch das team ist natürlich der
natur opa trauer hat knapp mit
behinderung beschäftigungsprogramm für
ein beschäftigungsprogramm für sich und
die affen
birgit ist gelang weil wir mit der
veranda beginnen müssen wir das noch
diskutieren
jörg ist der bauherr auf dem platz
birgit kann ihn nur beraten den von ihr
nehmen die arbeiter keine anweisungen
entgegen
[Musik]
dabei ist es meistens birgit welche die
baumängel entdeckt
das schöne für die bucht ein problem
tatsächlich der duschkopf ist viel zu
tief montiert york versucht den
bauarbeitern seinen änderungswunsch
verständlich zu machen
er geht die ehemalige schulleiterin kann
nur zuschauen
denn die autorität auf dem platz ist der
mann nicht und ich habe einfach ich
beschäftige mich
[Musik]
selbst im paradies braucht der mensch
eine aufgabe unglücklich zu sein
[Musik]
tashi hier ein stadtteil auf der
asiatischen seite istanbuls man immer
per tan in istanbul ist wohnen er und
monika bei seiner schwester nach land
[Applaus]
mal an und ihr ehemann sind nach
istanbul zurückgekehrt nachdem sie den
beiden auswanderern anfänglich in aller
hatte beim hotelbau geholfen hatten
werthan steckt sich eine zigarette an
seinen vorsatz in der neuen heimat nicht
mehr zu rauchen konnte er trotz der
familiären unterstützung nicht einhalten
jetzt auch ich eigentlich mehr als
vorher
ich brauche produkten pro tag jetzt eine
teil paket bis 2 paket geht überhaupt
nicht wie ich es in schweiz mir
vorgestellt habe
wegen den bauleuten wegen den
bauarbeiten nicht lange haben die kein
stress die nicht brauche kennen es nicht
dem gefühl du weinst du natürlich wir
haben nie geraucht
monika und wörtern sind nach istanbul
gereist weil sie ihr hotel perfekt
ausstatten wollen nur das beste ist gut
genug ihr hotel soll ein kleines juwel
werden
in der stadt am bosporus finden sie die
entsprechende auswahl um auch die
kleinen details nach ihren wünschen
gestalten zu können
jetzt mischen mir einen
[Musik]
die fähre bringt sie hinüber vom
asiatischen zum europäischen teil der
stadt
[Musik]
in williams lake haben sich die fischers
fürs erste auf einem campingplatz
eingerichtet
beim morgenkaffee sinnieren annett und
kurt darüber wie weit sich ihr wunsch
nach mehr lebensqualität und
familienzeit nun erfüllen wird
also hätte
sehr viel geld und ich das hier vor mir
vor augen wenn er schon frau bis 70
stunden wurden die familie vorerst wird
sich mutter annett ausschließlich um den
haushalt und den nachwuchs kümmern um
die 4 jährige christin und deren älteren
bruder freue sich einzig mit den kindern
zu beschäftigen ist für die ehemalige
lehrerin ungewohnt
für heute hat die familie ein spannendes
programm vor sich
die fischers gehen auf haussuche so
schnell wie möglich wollen sie eines
kaufen den neuen winter möchten sie auf
keinen fall auf dem campingplatz
verbringen müssen
eine klare vorstellung von einem haus
haben sie nicht nur eines wissen sie es
soll mitten in der natur stehen
george best der makler zeigt den
fischers ein erstes haus und was für
eines 280 quadratmeter wohnfläche zwei
hektaren umschwung preis 380.000
schweizer franken
es hat hier sehr viele ausgestopfte
tiere die bleiben hier beträgt gut ich
mache jede sowieso lieber draußen ja ich
auch ich liebe die küche das ist eine
ältere küche
das haus überzeugt das ehepaar nicht
einstieg das elternschlafzimmer in den
weiten kanadas das geht nicht
weiter geht's zur nächsten besichtigung
[Musik]
auf der europäischen seite istanbuls
angekommen
die harmonika und wärtern zum
altstadtviertel charakter
traditionell bieten in istanbul die
händler über ganze straßenzüge hinweg
die gleiche ware an
im caracol quartier reiht sich ein
elektrofachgeschäft ans andere
hier wollen sie lichtschalter und
steckdosen kaufen
[Musik]
hier gibt es ein modell mit drei
schaltern ist es möglich die schalter
auszutauschen ja das ist kein problem
welche farbe haben die wende unsere
wände sind aus stein
was kosten diese zwischen 18 und 20 ich
liebe halt die teuren sachen
bis 20 liter pro stück dann lassen wir
es bleiben
sie redet sehr gut türkisch sie versteht
es ja und das werden kommt auf ja das
kommt schon die beiden klappen mehrere
geschäfte ab und holen offerten ein
entscheiden wollen sie aber erst zu
hause in aller ruhe
[Musik]
jo
die prächtige unterwasserwelt lässt
bildet ihre verstimmung für den moment
vergessen ein breites korallenriff
vaters ehepaar aus opfikon nun direkt
vor seiner haustüre
[Musik]
nicht nur das meer auch die serie gehört
zum paradies
[Musik]
die angestellte ließ den auswanderern
jeden wunsch von den augen ab das war
okay wir haben keine zahnstocher für den
hamburger na ja er ist gigantisch ist
der für jörg selbst für das kleinste
problem hat désirée eine lösung parat
flint schnitzt sie aus bambus einen
zahnstocher
glücklich ohne jede persönliche
betreuung ist miss boyle die affendame
wurde von der leine gelassen
[Musik]
so habe ich es mir vorgestellt sondern
damit auch notiert auf vorgestellt ich
meine das ist gefragt und freiwilligkeit
[Musik]
die familie fischer schaut sich eine
weitere liegenschaft an sind sie rückt
das licht der neuen sie wollen ich
glaube die lichter sind schon angezündet
wie finden sind die größen der küche
die größe ist gut es ist sehr klein
nein für mich ist es gut dass sie ist
größer als unsere in der schweiz
für uns ist das eher eine kleine küche
[Musik]
jetzt eine riesige fenster prägen das
schlafzimmer der erste eindruck ist
bestechend
doch kurt der zimmermann ist eben kein
gewöhnlicher hauskäufer code wird immer
skeptischer das ist es noch nicht so gut
und man ist schon einiges machen
also eines ist dies eben immer noch
bestand oder unternehmen muss man da
müssen wir machen
auch dieses haus kostet 380 tausend
schweizer franken
doch es müsste noch aufwendig renoviert
werden für die aargauer ist das zu
kostspielig
meines ministeriums
wenn es doch dennis tito
[Musik]
der stau zu ende
auf ihre einkaufstour verbinden die
auswanderer monika und berta das
nützliche mit dem schönen sie besuchen
da tanz eltern
[Musik]
ich schaue zuerst etwas wert tanz eltern
wohnen nördlich von istanbul in chile
einem kleinen badeort am schwarzen meer
also ich kaufe zum vater und vom
parlament sondern blaue fisch kleine wie
viel kosten einen hart kilo 20 lehrer
gib mir zweimal ein
obwohl wörtern wieder in seinem
mutterland zurückgekehrt ist oft zieht
er seine eltern nicht
[Musik]
dazu gekippt danke ich brauche keine
hausschuhe
[Musik]
ich nehme dir die jacke ab gott segne
euch diesen fisch mag ich sehr
[Musik]
den kochen hier gleich heute abend ja
dann guten appetit
die früchte wer hat bert ans mutter für
monika gebacken damit sich ihre
schwiegertochter willkommen und zu hause
fühlt burtons mutter weiß wie es sich
anfühlt die heimat zu verlassen
wegen der arbeit wanderten sie und ihr
mann in jungen jahren nach deutschland
aus nach 28 jahren in der fremde kehrten
sie wieder heim in die türkei wir hatten
nicht so viel zeit aber wir wollten
trotzdem zu euch vorbeikommen und hallo
sagen und deswegen
das zusammensein im schoße der familie
dauert nur kurze zeit denn auf monika
und burtons einkaufsliste sind noch
nicht alle besorgungen erledigt
[Musik]
du musst deine charakters birgit hat
seit kurzem gesundheitliche probleme mit
ihren füßen ihr leiden hält sie aber
nicht davon ab mit so helfen das jungle
beat schild am eingang ihres resorts
aufzustellen
zweimal ist birgit gestürzt
einfach so
[Applaus]
eigentlich wäre es ein freudiger moment
endlich das schild mit dem namen des
eigenen ressort aufzustellen
doch die sorgen um birgit trüben jörg
stimmer
jetzt hat sich auch schaurige hier
kaufen
einige mühe mit dem ruf von bisher
bestimmt nicht und dennoch aktion der
einfachen aufbaus dem schild tragen
aber sie hat wirklich treiben so jetzt
sieht das anders ich nicht irgendwann
bin ich dann stand da ist der ton karton
halt mal bietet damit dich schauen kann
kloster
[Musik]
ok
das schild hängt ein wichtiger schritt
ist getan ehepaar sense jungle beat ist
zwar noch nicht eröffnet aber immerhin
schon zu finden
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
verschlimmern sich birgit probleme mit
den füßen
[Musik]
keiner weiß warum sie nicht mehr richtig
gehen kann
großeinkauf beim porzellan händler
monika und bernd dann zerschlagen verbal
einiges an geschick in kanada findet die
familie fischer aus dem aargau ihr
traumhaus und freundet sich beim
kürbisschnitzen mit dem camper nachbarn
an
dabei kommen
si
[Musik]